When Pixar began developing the third Cars
movie, they decided to return to the roots
of the franchise with a story centred firmly
around Lightning McQueen.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in this video I'm going to explain all
the deleted scenes, original stories and alternate
endings that Pixar developed for Cars 3 during
five years of production but that didn't make
it into the final movie.
Also I'm running my Cars 3 giveaway for two
The Art of Cars 3 hardback books on this video.
If you'd like a chance to win one of these
two very cool books which feature gorgeous
concept art and storyboards from Cars 3, be
sure to subscribe, leave a comment about the
film, and also answer the question I'll be
asking later in the video.
Quick warning, I will be discussing spoilers
in this video, so take care if you haven't
seen the movie yet.
After director John Lasseter made the first
Cars movie, he was really keen for legendary
actor Paul Newman to return as the voice of
Doc Hudson for the sequel.
Sadly though, Newman passed away in 2008,
and while Cars 2 does make brief mention of
Doc, details of how Doc died were never revealed
in that movie.
However, in an interview with Screencrush,
Cars creative director Jay Ward explained
that he had hoped to remedy the lack of details
about Doc's passing in Cars 3.
In fact, in an early version of the movie,
there was going to be a flashback that would
have revealed how Doc died.
Ward described the deleted scene as "a really
tender moment where McQueen [is] driving and
Doc's following him and it's like the day
your mentor passes away."
Although Pixar loves to make us cry, the scene
was cut because, as Ward himself said, it
was "just depressing".
I still think that this could have been an
interesting scene to include as although many
Cars and Pixar fans enjoyed Cars 3, many still
want to know what really happened to Doc.
And, as Pixar proved in their incredible introductory
montage of Carl and Ellie in Up, a character's
death can provide a deeper emotional connection
to a movie and its story.
One of the best moments in the new movie is
when Lightning, Cruz and Mack go incognito
at the Thunder Hollow demolition derby.
Lightning covers himself in mud and takes
on the name of Chester Whipplefilter, Cruz
uses the alias Frances Beltline, and Mack
wears a Jocko Flocko disguise, which, if you've
watched my Cars 3 easter eggs video, you'll
know is a sneaky easter egg to a real-life
NASCAR monkey racer.
But the theme of Team 95 operating and training
under cover was originally going to be a much
more extended and long-running joke throughout
the movie.
For example, initially the beach training
scene was going to be set up as a pretend
movie shoot where Guido was an Italian film
director and Lightning was an actor pretending
to be Lightning McQueen.
A bunch of other gags about the team travelling
around in disguise were also cut from the
final film, for example, Mack was going to
conceal his identity in various ways ranging
from a travelling circus to a shipping container,
and from a military vehicle to a lumberjack.
The character of Cruz Ramirez was very different
in early drafts of the story and initially
she was actually a male car, but the filmmakers
decided to make her a female car so she was
more of an outsider in the typically male-dominated
world of motor racing.
Originally, Cruz was also going to be a young
rookie racer rather than a trainer and an
early idea was that when Lightning met her
at the Rust-Eze Training Centre, he would
see her as a younger version of himself, in
a very similar way to how Doc viewed Lightning
when he first met him in the first movie.
In the end though, the filmmakers felt this
was re-treading too much of the story from
Cars 1, so they began to make her more of
an opposite character to Lightning, for example
in the way she lacked confidence.
Ultimately, the movie's creators believed
these changes to Cruz's character helped build
a more interesting story by developing a more
odd-couple-style of relationship between Lightning
and his new trainer.
The relationship between Lightning and Cruz
culminates in the Florida 500 Piston Cup event
where, midway through the race, Lightning
realises that Cruz is the answer to beating
Jackson Storm, so he calls her back for his
pit stop but instead of going back out himself,
he gives her his number 95 and tells her to
race in his place.
Before settling on this final twist though,
the filmmakers considered a whole bunch of
alternate endings.
In one of those alternatives, Lightning never
took part in the final race at all and entered
Cruz into the race instead, presenting her
as the "New 95" to his friends from Radiator
Springs before the event.
This ending didn't work well because the filmmakers
found that there was a sense that the movie
was already finished at the point that Lightning
decided to stop racing which meant that the
remaining story felt underwhelming.
In another ending, McQueen ran the whole race
himself, won it, and then he decided to mentor
Cruz only at the very end of the movie.
However, this ending made the film "feel hollow",
according to director Brian Fee.
In yet another version, they both took part
in the race and had to compete against each
other, but that didn't work either because
it split the audience over who to support.
In the end, the filmmakers decided that, to
get the right level of tension in the movie's
final act, they would have Lightning pass
on his number mid-race to Cruz.
But even then, there were further variations
considered within this scene.
For example, at one point, this passing of
the torch to Cruz was going to be more fraught
with McQueen getting angry at her when she
didn't understand what was going on, though
finally they both would have come to a proper
understanding and appreciation of each other.
I'm not sure quite how I feel about the way
the number 95 was passed to Cruz in the final
film, as although Smokey explained that "the
rules only say the number has to be out there,
doesn't say who has to wear it", the confusion
it initially created meant this transition
wasn't quite as smooth as I would have liked.
The Cars 3 filmmakers obviously spent a lot
of time considering all the possible options,
but I still wonder whether there was another
way to have done this that didn't raise quite
so many questions in my mind while I was watching
it.
What do you think about the ending?
Did you enjoy it or would you have preferred
something different?
By the way, there are some interesting storyboards
which hint at a deleted scene or another alternate
ending where McQueen reveals his transformation
into the Fabulous Lightning McQueen at the
Piston Cup race rather than at the very end
of the movie.
You can see him emerging with Doc's colours
and the number 51 to a group of press, then
the crowd and, finally, onto the racetrack
where he faces up to Jackson Storm.
In the final movie, the reveal of the "Fabulous
Lightning McQueen" is a much more private
moment for Lightning with his friends at Radiator
Springs.
Although the movie's final scene of Lightning
unveiling his homage to Doc Hudson was lovely,
these storyboards hint that the filmmakers
considered a much more dramatic and symbolic
way of 'bringing Doc back to life through
his protégé', to quote story supervisor
Scott Morse, by having Lightning announce
his new number and colours at the Piston Cup.
I'm not sure if this would have fit the way
the rest of the ending played out, but perhaps
fans of Doc Hudson especially would have enjoyed
seeing this scene.
Production on Cars 3 began at Pixar in 2013,
but it wasn't until 2015 that the final direction
of the story was decided on after John Lasseter
was inspired by the retirement of his friend,
professional NASCAR racer, Jeff Gordon at
the age of 43.
Which means that, during those 2 years, various
fascinating ideas and stories were considered
for the sequel.
Some of those early ideas involved returning
to Route 66 and also including Route 99 and
racing on dry bed lakes (insert pictures).
One idea that was developed in a little more
detail was an exploration of Southern California
car culture plus celebrity culture in LA.
In an interview with ScreenJunkies News, director
Brian Fee revealed that in one early story
Lightning "went to a Hollywood Hills party
and it was full of actors, and we had the
old Batmobile and the new Batmobile talking
to each other at a party."
Obviously, this was a whole other story, but
I imagine this scene could have been a lot
of fun as we already saw car versions of Pixar
movie characters from Toy Story, Monsters
University, and A Bug's Life in the credits
for the first Cars movie, and I imagine there
could have been a lot of potential for jokes
and voice cameos by previous Batman actors
or sound-alikes.
I also wonder whether an LA-based story might
have explored Sally's past history in the
city.
If you recall, in the first Cars movie, we
learned that Sally was originally a hot-shot
lawyer in Los Angeles, and it could have been
interesting to see her backstory explored.
So, are there any deleted scenes or stories
you would love to have seen in Cars 3?
And do you think there should be a fourth
Cars movie and, if so, what would you like
to see happen?
For a chance to win this awesome The Art of
Cars 3 hardback book, be sure to subscribe,
and leave a comment about the movie, and also
answer the following question:
What famous superhero car almost appeared
in Cars 3?
Turn on your notifications to get all my new
videos where I'll be announcing the winners
of the giveaway.
Plus, let me know what deleted scenes you
liked me to do in future videos, and if you
enjoyed this, hit that thumbs-up button and
check out more of my movie deleted scenes
and Pixar videos right here.
Congratulations to these three winners of
my Arrow, Flash and Supergirl giveaways who
are on the screen now!
If you're one of them, send me a message on
YouTube or via my email which you can find
on my About page.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers!